--
AFTER THE U.S. PRESIDENT
PROMISED TO QUOTE, FREE IRAN.
THE PRESIDENT REPLIED THAT HIS
COUNTRY WAS FREED 43 YEARS AGO.
RALLIES WERE HELD ON FRIDAY,
NEW YORK AND JUST A DAY AGO WE
SAW AND GOVERNMENT
DEMONSTRATIONS IN THE CAPITAL,
WITH AT LEAST THREE OTHER
CITIES.
MARKING 40 DAYS SINCE THE
KILLING OF --
FOLLOWING THE STORY FROM DAY
ONE, AND JOMANA, THESE PROTESTS
ARE IN THEIR SEVENTH WEEK, AND
AS IT ESCALATES, WHAT ARE YOU
HEARING FROM YOUR CONTACTS ON
THE GROUND?
>> WHAT I THINK REALLY SUMS UP
THE SITUATION IN IRAN RIGHT NOW,
ABOUT A WEEK AGO ON SATURDAY WE
HEARD FROM THE HEAD OF THE
POWERFUL AND REVOLUTIONARY
GUARD CORPS, ISSUING WARNINGS
TO PROTESTERS TELLING THEM THAT
SATURDAY WOULD BE THEIR LAST
DAY OUT ON THE STREETS, AND THE
PEOPLE'S RESPONSE TO THAT
ULTIMATUM?
MORE PROTESTS.
WE HAVE SEEN PROTESTS ACROSS
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE COUNTRY,
WE HAVE SEEN LARGE PROTESTS AND
SOME OF THEM ON TURNING REALLY
VIOLENT, WE SAW TODAY IN THE
SOUTHEASTERN PART OF THE
COUNTRY, HOME TO THE BALOCH
MINORITY, A NUMBER OF CITIES
THERE, VIOLENCE ERA DID.
ACCORDING TO AMNESTY
INTERNATIONAL THEY SAY THAT THE
GOVERNMENT FORCES OPENED FIRE
ON PEACEFUL PROTESTERS.
THEY SAY THAT THEY WERE
SHOOTING AT THEM FROM THE
ROOFTOPS OF GOVERNMENT
BUILDINGS.
THEY FEEL THAT AT LEAST TEN
PEOPLE MAY HAVE BEEN KILLED,
INCLUDING CHILDREN.
THE GOVERNMENT'S VERSION OF
EVENTS, THEY SAY THAT IT WAS
PROTESTERS WHO ATTACKED THESE
GOVERNMENT BUILDINGS.
THEY CLAIM THAT PROTESTERS WERE
CARRYING WEAPONS.
WE HAVE NOT SEEN ANYTHING THAT
SUPPORTS THROUGH THESE CLAIMS
BY THE GOVERNMENT AT THIS
POINT.
AS WE HAVE SEEN OVER THE PAST
SEVEN WEEKS, THE GOVERNMENT HAS
BEEN USING BRUTAL FORCE.
BEATING AND SHOOTING A
PROTESTERS TO TRY TO CRUSH THIS
NATIONAL UPRISING.
SO FAR IT DOES NOT SEEM TO BE
WORKING.
REALLY DISTURBING INFORMATION
WE HAVE GOTTEN THIS WEEK FROM
UN OFFICIALS, SAYING THAT AT
LEAST 14,000 PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
ARRESTED IN THIS CRACKDOWN.
MANY OF THEM FACING THE DEATH
PENALTY, IN A COUNTRY WHERE
MANY PEOPLE AND ORGANIZATIONS
WILL TELL YOU THAT THERE IS NO
SUCH THING AS FREE TRIALS.
THAT INCLUDES ONE VERY POPULAR
DISSIDENTS RAPPER.
♪ ♪ ♪
>> THESE ARE THE LYRICS THAT
COULD COST HIM HIS LIFE.
THE IRANIAN RAP ARTIST WAS
ARRESTED LAST WEEKEND, FOR
CRIMES PUNISHABLE BY DEATH.
BUT HIS REAL CRIME, HIS MUSIC
CALLING ON IRANIANS TO RISE UP
AND REMOVE THE OPPRESSIVE
REGIME.
[NOISE] TOOMAJ SALEHI HAS ALSO
PROUDLY POSTED THESE VIDEOS
RECENTLY, OUT AT THE PROTESTS,
LEADING FOR CHANGE.
FAMILY MEMBERS SAY HE WAS
ARRESTED ALONG WITH TWO FRIENDS
IN A VIOLENT RAID ON SUNDAY.
HIS UNCLE TELLS CNN THEY HAVE
INFORMATION THAT HE WAS
TORTURED.
>> WE STILL DO NOT KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT TOOMAJ SALEHI
HEALTH OR CONDITION.
THE FAMILY TRIED HARD TO EVEN
HEAR HIS VOICE.
NO ONE HAS GIVEN US ANY
INFORMATION.
WE DO NOT KNOW IF ALL OF HIS
FRIENDS ARE ALIVE OR NOT.
WE WANT TO KNOW WHAT HAPPENED
TO OUR BOYS AND WHAT TORTURE
HAS ISLAMIC GOVERNMENT GIVEN
HIM.
>> THIS SHORT EDITED CLIP MEDIA
ON WEDNESDAY, CLAIMING TO SHOW
TOOMAJ SALEHI EXPRESSING THE
WAR OUTRAGE.
HIS FAMILY BELIEVE THAT IT IS
NOT EVEN TOOMAJ SALEHI.
THE UNDERGROUND RAPPER HAS BEEN
TERRIBLE FOR YEARS, WITH
POLITICALLY-CHARGED LYRICS,
SPEAKING OUT AGAINST CORRUPTION,
POVERTY, HE WAS ARRESTED LAST
YEAR, BUT THIS TIME IS
DIFFERENT.
THE REGIME IS STRUGGLING TO
CONTAIN THE NATIONAL UPRISING.
UNLEASHING ALL ITS BRUTAL
TACTICS.
THOUSANDS HAVE BEEN ARRESTED,
MORE THAN 1000 INDICTED, AND
PROTESTERS ACCUSED OF WAGING
WAR AGAINST GOD AND CORRUPTION
ON EARTH, FACING THE DEATH
PENALTY IN WHAT HUMAN RIGHTS
GROUPS SAY OUR SHAM TRIALS.
MANY FEAR THE RUTHLESS REPUBLIC
WILL HAND TOOMAJ SALEHI AND
OTHERS THE HARSHEST OF
SENTENCES TO MAKE THEM AN
EXAMPLE TO THOSE WHO DARE TO
DISSENT.
>> [SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH]
TOOMAJ THIS MOTHER WAS A
POLITICAL PRISONER, WHO PASSED
AWAY A LONG TIME AGO.
IF SHE WAS STILL ALIVE, SHE
WOULD HAVE BECOME TOOMAJ'S
VOICE.
THE SAME AS I AM, THE SAME OF
EVERYONE ON THE STREETS.
>> A VOICE THEY TRIED TO
SILENCE, NOW LOUDER AND MORE
POWERFUL THAN EVER.
>> [SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH]
>> TOOMAJ THIS FAMILY VERY
CONCERNED, HIS UNCLE ASKING US
TO SEND A MESSAGE TO THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY, TO DO
SOMETHING TO SAVE TOOMAJ AND
OTHERS.
>> ANOTHER HEARTBREAKING STORY
THAT YOU ARE BRINGING US.
I CAN'T THINK OF WHAT THIS
FAMILY, THE UNCLE AND THE REST
OF THE FAMILY ARE GOING THROUGH,
WAITING FOR WORD ON HOW HE IS
DOING.
LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT IF THERE
HAS BEEN ANY REACTION TO
POLITICS FROM WHAT WE HEARD
FROM PRESIDENT BIDEN ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL, WHEN HE SAID,
DON'T WORRY, WE ARE GOING TO
FREE IRAN, WHAT HAS THE
REACTION BEEN ON THE GROUND OF
THOSE WORDS?
>> THE REACTION THAT WE HAVE
SEEN FROM THE IRANIAN PRESIDENT
AS YOU HAVE SEEN EARLIER, TODAY
MARKING THE 1979 TAKEOVER OF
THE U.S. EMBASSY, THAT
ANNIVERSARY, EVERY YEAR, WHERE
YOU SEE THE PRO GOVERNMENT
CROWDS ON THE STREETS, IN IRAN,
OUTSIDE WHAT USED TO BE THE
U.S. EMBASSY, WE SAW THAT AGAIN,
THE USUAL CHANTS OF DEATH TO
ISRAEL AND DEATH TO AMERICA.
AND YOU HAVE THE IRANIAN
PRESIDENT ADDRESSING THOSE
CROWNS AND HE SAID THAT HE WAS
INFORMED THAT THE COMMENTS MADE
BY PRESIDENT BIDEN, --
ABSENTMINDEDLY SAID WE WILL
SOON FOR IRAN, WE HAVE BEEN
FREE FOR 43 YEARS.
SAYING THEY WILL NOT ALLOW THE
U.S. AND OTHERS TO TURN IRAN
INTO ANOTHER SYRIA OR LIBYA.
AGAIN, DISMISSING ALL THAT WE
HAVE BEEN SEEING ON THE STREETS,
THE ANGER OF THE PEOPLE AND THE
DEMANDS OF THEIR OWN POPULATION
AS SOME KIND OF FOREIGN
CONSPIRACY.
RIOTS TO TRY TO DESTABILIZE THE
COUNTRY BY THE U.S.